welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about whether hell
is canon in the marvel cinematic
universe and whether to i guess
cross-paraphrase odin in jean-paul
hell is not a place it is another piece
of pronunciation it was all over the
place i think
almost nailed it i'm eric voss
hey here with me to journey through the
mcu afterlife is marino
mastros i'm back guys welcome back
alive well fitting because that's what
we're talking about today
right on the cusp of while we alive we
did what happens to us
i don't think you were ever truly a
death story we don't want to worry our
viewers too much but uh we're happy to
see you
uh semi healthy healthy enough to to be
back on new rocks
oh yes i'm happy to be here um eric i
have a question for you though
oh how does the afterlife work
in the mcu yes a very good question
especially now that black panther 2 is
kind of moving forward with production
this summer a producer on the series
confirming that they're not going to be
trying to recreate the late chadwick
bozeman's likeness with vfx
think boss honestly we would not want to
see that but uh this brings up the
question of black panther you know more
than any other mcu installment has
totally embraced that idea of death of
spirituality the afterlife
and yeah i think whatever they do with
this movie they're gonna have to lean
more into what the ancestral plane
is and in order to know what's coming up
we should dig into this question of
what happens or how based on the real
world
is the mcu version of the afterlife well
going through the mcu as of now we have
seen
seven established versions of the
afterlife
in mcu canon but also on top of that
there's like two or three additional
sort of realms or afterlives that we
might be able to infer based on clues or
things that might be after life e
um so we're gonna break down all of
these
to see if any of these could be the same
afterlife or if there's any crossover
if we can group any of these together to
make any big statements about
what happens when an avenger dies and
even though there's seven of them
eric and i won't be getting into any no
we won't uh unless it's the dark ones
and we're already in them all right
let's start with the big one that we
know about the ancestral plane from uh
the black panther film the wakandan
afterlife so
the ancestral plain of wakanda is based
on dejalia in the black panther comics
it's a spiritual realm where the black
panther can commune
with their ancestors and the plane
seems only accessible by those who
consume the heart-shaped herb
and they get buried right which
symbolize your death your cross soon
over
i think it might still be an afterlife
for all wakandans because
njobu killmonger's dad is there and he
was never a black panther he was part of
the royal lineage
yeah but he was not a black panther he
never consumed the heart shape okay
yeah i mean that makes total sense and
you also if all wakandans get to go
there
i'm pretty sure they all get to turn
into panthers because they were all cats
when they jumped off the tree
that's right that's kind of part of it
right it's uh that's how t'challa saw
them they it was this kind of this
interesting
subjective quality right that you
commune with the souls that are
important to
you in this moment it doesn't seem like
it's a
an actual just party where all these
ghosts are hanging out together before
you get there
they seem to be anchored to where they
were buried so to chalices to chaka who
was buried in wakanda with those
ancestors but killmonger sees in jobu
but the version of that
is their oakland apartment because
that's where he was buried he says he
was abandoned in oakland
so i think that's an interesting take on
the afterlife is that it is
specifically tailored for the person who
is visiting it in that moment it's not
an
external realm that exists before you
and that makes sense just like in
general if you're taking
if you're creating a whole world and an
entire society
they would have their own religious
beliefs and those beliefs would
be reflective of the ones that exist in
real life and that
is how a lot of real cultures perceive
the afterlife it's it's not a place that
exists before you get there it is a
place
it's an experience that is a
transitional thing that is
meant to help you embrace the fact that
you don't need to be part of a corporeal
world anymore you know
and speaking of that that brings us to
our our second uh afterlife
thing that we've seen the astral
dimension of the doctor strange film the
sorcerer realm
which kind of tells us that there is an
existence of souls in the mcu and
you know that's interesting because it
tells us a bit about where they go
it kind of has to be because it's in
multiple films in multiple
different versions but i like that they
let everybody experience it in their own
way
but it's i mean it's like definite for
me it exists and
many actually believe the ancestral
plane of the black panther is the same
thing as the astral dimension of doctor
strange because yeah they do kind of
work similarly
souls of the living detach from their
corporeal bodies and commune with other
souls
but the big difference is that the
sorcerer's soul appears to disappear the
moment of their
corporeal death so when the ancient one
flatlines her soul vanished from that
astral dimension doctor strange was left
alone
so you could argue that the astral
dimension is less of an afterlife
than it is like a parallel plane to the
mortar yeah
and also you can get there before you
die and sort of float around have we
explored where you go
because she disappears but we don't know
if that means she's gone forever because
she maybe she can come back into that
parallel universe we don't know
we don't know um and from what we can
tell
obviously death is not necessarily final
in the mcu people come back in all kinds
of forms whether it's
through a multiverse alternate reality
or uh in
one division's case yeah whatever that's
gonna end up being rebooted
you know yeah with tony stark with
certain other characters there is
like another precipice on the other side
of these transitional realms
to where it is just bliss it is just
nothing and we can't understand that as
humans but
it's it could be a great thing it could
be a scary thing well we'll get more
into that because there's there's
some things that kind of start to broach
that subject yeah starting with
the soul realm this is the orange
colored soul dimension
uh that we saw on infinity war and end
game when characters use all six stones
to at the same time destroy
or to bring back souls they briefly
enter this orange colored plane and it's
described as
uh the word used was an existential way
station
that's what the filmmakers called it and
it's before they either move on or
before they return to reality
so thanos met with gamora when she was a
young girl that form and then a tony
stark this was in a deleted scene he met
with morgan stark
as an older young woman and the
filmmakers actually said they considered
a scene which banner when he snapped
everyone back
would have met with the soul of natasha
in that moment
that would have tugged everyone's heart
strings yeah that would have been great
and
you know the vfx artists working on it
didn't really understand fully what it
meant they
you know when they worked on infinity
war one point they considered making the
fluid surface to be an
ocean of blood for thanos uh and the
filmmaker's like um
no no this will just all be taking place
in kind of this fluid space
that's inside the soul stone they were
like but you don't want an ocean of
blood i don't understand
he's like all right we're going to save
the ocean of blood for another movie
because we're using the
blood it's going in somewhere
but the fact that it's kind of inside
the soul stone you could argue it's like
kind of a pocket reality that is opened
up by the soul stone that you briefly
enter
so what's important about this is like
the ancestral plane like the astral
dimension the soul realm appears to be
temporary it's not a permanent afterlife
it's kind of like an ethereal plane
that's you know again constructed for a
soul to transition
to process what's happening to them
before they return to the living world
or they move on to the other
way parallel it to like the concept of
purgatory yeah purgatory or limbo
you know it's for a lot of people that
is what the afterlife is especially if
you watch something like the good place
without spoiling that series it's so
good
but like you know the good place once
you do eventually see it people are like
well then what's
next what is that after this well what
is after this is
just bliss it's just letting go of
everything no longer existing
and that's okay
you got it you jumped
i knew it i freaking knew yeah
all right let's move on to our fourth
afterlife in the mcu we have not
actually seen this but it exists
valhalla
this is the uh norse version of the
afterlife in the thor movies
we never went there but we saw people go
to it odin and his wife rega both
ascended to valhalla
they disintegrated into glowing
particles and they floated up to the
heavens
now valhalla is reserved uniquely for
asgardians who
die in combat it's a warrior afterlife
in norse mythology
half of the fallen warriors are led by
the valkyries to valhalla
while the other half go to the goddess
freyjas fields
folk finder nailed it
yeah i think i was closer and i like
this idea of a warrior after life
because in thor the dark world
frigga died in combat she was a badass
in that final moment that is what led to
her passing on the valhalla and ragnarok
odin did not die in the heat of battle
he did die of old age but
that guy has fought his entire life
traditionally valhalla is his realm
so i would say he's enough of a veteran
to warrant that destination
so here's where we reach kind of the
interesting
midpoint of even though it's the fifth
one that we're doing um the
blimp the blip is something right it is
something
i mean it has to be because you spend
five years there so right it is
where or what happened to all the dusted
in infinity war and in-game
that disintegration of odin does
parallel the dusting disintegration of
snap victims suggesting you know this
idea fading
into death however where the blip
victims went remains a mystery it's
presumed they were just
transferred directly to the idea of
non-existence no
limbo no purgatory just skipped directly
to death
you know fastpass but then peter parker
returned an end game and he described
the experience of tony stark as having
no memory of that intervening period it
was just like one second he dusted the
next he was back and dr strange was like
come on we gotta go fight and it's
interesting in the infinity gauntlet
comic that infinity war is based on rick
jones gets snapped away and when he
returns he says that he met
elvis so that would imply you
went somewhere right my god does that
imply that elvis
also got snapped and was still alive at
the time oh yeah infinity gauntlet comic
gets crazy
elf uh alf shows up in the infinity
gauntlet comics
like celebrities snap it's it's like the
leftovers where they're like the pope
snap gary busey's
you know it's insane now i'm gonna
mention this even though it's not mcu
cannon
you know netflix daredevil punisher
universe the defenders on netflix when
black sky returns
resurrected by the hand alexandra tells
her quote you were born
you lived and died and what you saw on
the other side
the darkness the absence of everything
it's horrifying
isn't it so that darkness could be
referring to some of what these other
things we've seen
in the mcu and i bring this up marina
because so far we've been talking about
the positive afterlifes
the good places they're all kind of warm
ethereal family reuniting transitory but
the blip represents a kind of just
neutral death
yeah again you do not pass go you just
go directly
to death but now we move on to the mcu
afterlifes that are kind of jails
they're they're
negative they're bad places ones that
offer
actually more tangible but permanent
prisons
and we'll start here with the uh the
sixth afterlife we know about the dark
dimension
this is the timeless dimension of
dormammu in the doctor strange film
it's a parallel plane of reality in
which chaos raises and you get
[ __ ] up makeup when you go there and
you come back your makeup
gets tough oh it's a mess
it's a mess your mascara is running all
over your face and you can't do anything
about it and
when kaiselius and his uh zealots get
sucked in there
their souls get transformed into these
mindless gray
husks yeah and if you were to ask people
on the street
if you were to go jaywalking and say
what do you think hell is oh my god this
is so hard i bet you'd get 4 out of 10
people be like uh a psychedelic space
where everything's glowing
and i can't think and it's forever and
it's like oh you mean the dark dimension
they're like yeah that sounds right yeah
and they're all from the south
that would be my first guess too yes
there you go take it
yes that's what i would consider hell to
be
but you know for people who love black
light posters they might think it's
heaven
get america get them losers and new
spencer's gifts
that was me i was down that was me i was
like yes fill my room with black lights
and they're like you don't want normal
bulbs i'm like no everything's gonna be
purple and i screwed and that's like
oh no everything's glowing gross goes
gross
okay but yeah at the other day still
this is terrifying and
in the mcu we got dangerously close to
losing everything we know
and love to that yeah so everybody
almost turned into a pillar of salt or
whatever
gray dusty salt oh yeah that's hell bad
as hell except
this version of hell number seven hell
h-e-l just one l
that was hella's banishment realm that
we saw in the thor movies
this is the place hello was banished to
uh it is actually a region within
niflheim one of the nine realms
now presumably marina hell was named
after hella
got there because it would be weird that
would exist
before and then hella would just be
named after this place but then would
get set there's kind of a
self-fulfilling prophecy it's like they
mean your son rikers
and be like you know where you're going
she landed like jack skellington in
christmas town and looked up and it just
said hella and she was like
then she's sang a song so odin banished
hella to hell
thousands of years ago and it's a bunch
of [ __ ] because she shouldn't have
gotten banished there she was just doing
what thor did but she was a woman
and that's why she got banned she's a
bunch of [ __ ] and i had made the
case that hella
was the most misunderstood villain she
would have been great as a ruler of
asgard
she just didn't have great diplomacy and
didn't care about trying to win over
hearts and minds she also
got done dirty in the wig department in
that movie like
they just did i don't know i love those
antlers oh the antlers yes but whenever
she had like real hair i was like ooh
girl oh just the
they did you dirty with that but yes
eric thank you for speaking up
because she got done dirty and she would
have been great i love helen i want her
to come back she needs to be the new
like uh loki in all of these movies like
but
she's blanchette she's like i'll do one
of these and then
yeah so she was stuck down there for
thousands of years
she tried to escape once she failed and
then she did escape again after odin
croaked
now again kind of like the astral
dimension this version of hell is not
really an afterlife it's just kind of a
prison
like hello was still alive down there
she didn't return there i don't think
when she died in ragnarok
so that is our our seventh one but that
brings us to
what we think is coming up some other
possible afterlifes that have been
implied based off what we know where
things are going hell
two l's in the mcu so this would be a
more
traditional version of hell and it might
exist going forward in the mcu it could
be
tied to the fire and brimstone aesthetic
of the realm of muspelheim
and you know remember the opening
sequence of ragnarok but if
mephisto exists so must help yeah
that's interesting yes it is and it's so
[ __ ]
cool because we're gonna get ghost rider
from there we're gonna get everything
supernatural and demonic coming from
there hopefully it's going to tie into
watervision
now technically mephisto does exist in
the mcu
if you consider everything on screen in
the mcu to be canon mephisto
showed up as a barely visible piece of
text easter egg on a file in the very
first avengers film
this is before that they knew exactly
how they're gonna adapt infinity
gauntlet
maybe that's why it was put in there
they laid their bed and now they have to
lie in it yeah as i said many of us
think that mephisto might be behind what
we're seeing in monovision
hopefully that will be what we see going
forward that might be behind
why scott derrickson left from doctor
strange with multiverse madness because
they wouldn't let him bring in hell into
that
because it would cause problems if they
tried to market doctor strange and the
multiverse madness in china and they
don't like
things in their movies you know because
they're you know culture their folklore
and
very censorship reasons but they can do
it on disney plus disney plus isn't
going to be
in china and that's maybe why they moved
it into one division
we'll find out now i also want to talk
about the quantum realm the quantum
realm obviously exists in mcu hard to
describe as an afterlife because
it really doesn't have anything to do
with death or spirituality but
it does remain the biggest what the [ __ ]
mystery box currently in the mcu
so sure that could be what the mcu
considers an afterlife if they were to
say
everything beyond this plane is the
quantum realm i'm thinking they might
also merge it with a negative zone
yeah from fantastic four there's a lot
of things they could do with it and they
could also say that's also where you go
when you die well i mean if nothing else
you can
exist there and time doesn't function
the same so
that in itself you could argue that that
in itself is a sort of afterlife
yeah it's a kind of afterlife uh and the
last one we're going to talk about is
the cancer verse
uh so in the adnet and lanning marvel
comics following characters like quasar
the new guardians of the galaxy
nova there is this crazy because comics
dimension called the cancer verse
there are these cosmic entities called
the many angled ones i love it
and they found a way to defeat death and
give eternal life but
in this dimension every inhabitant is
corrupted in a way that makes this kind
of universe-wide living corpse
thus the cancer it's insane now there
were some theories in the mcu that that
one shot of meredith quill in guardians
of the galaxy meredith
died from brain cancer could be her kind
of soul
reaching out from the cancer verse i
think james gunn debunked it
but the way that she reached out to
peter quill in the moment he saw her he
said mom there was something that he was
in
if you want to call that the ancestral
plane or the astral dimension or that
limbo state
he was in a different state of
consciousness there yeah
you could argue that these are all just
like the same thing
but coming through with different
representations of like who you are
and also yes this is crazy because like
never underestimate the connection of a
mom with her kid mommy's coming little
billy
there's like real ass stories
where something happens to your kid and
a mom will much later
like realize that she woke up at the
exact time that something was happening
and it's like
that shit's real and i'm glad they like
bothered to include it
and i think because it's so real is why
it's so impactful when we see that in
the film
you know these movies that's why i think
why we love the marvel movies they
aren't just comic book easter eggs they
have these human
moments that like transcend just like
simple plot actions it's
it's real moments of connection that are
beautiful and
marina you make such an interesting
point right the mcu versions of the
afterlife are all kind of connected
in that way they might all be the same
type of good place or the same type of
bad place
the whole time think about it they all
have that in common they're all kind of
transitiony
warm family reunions you could argue
that each of them are just what the
dying person sees when they're about to
cross over and on the other side of that
is that bliss it's that kind of good
place walking through the forest
uh and that's kind of what they all have
in common the ancestral plane the astral
dimension the soul
realm valhalla they they could all just
be different words of the same
thing but what's cool about this and
what i'm excited about
all the bad afterlifes yeah they're all
also the same they're all
tangible places that you get trapped in
they're all prisons
they're all divided and they're all
scary and they tell us going forward
that hell
if all these things are just shades of
hell is going to be very real
in the mcu and real things like ghost
rider are going to come
charging out of those firings
so get excited for it if nicolas cage
comes back
i'm gonna [ __ ] my pants it can't be nick
cage hopefully he
like has a cameo but it can't be nick
cage wait wait i just my
phone fell down because you were so eric
i love you but
i swear to god it's gonna be nick cage
or bust i think that's what nick cage
screamed at you outside your window last
night
it's gotta be me
it's like when samuel jackson was like i
won't be in snakes on a plane unless
it's called snakes on a plane
i've had it with these monkey fighting
snakes on this monday to friday
nick cage was like it's gonna be me
the ghost of ghost writer is like i'm
not going to let you put me in the movie
yeah that's exactly it all right we're
going to move on to some more questions
first we want to thank our friends at
hawthorne whether you are treating
yourself or shopping for someone
on your list finding the right holiday
gift is tough this holiday season
hawthorne is making
gifts giving fun and simple hawthorne is
a premium tailored personal care brand
that
makes it easy for guys to feel and smell
their best
you start with their quiz they ask you
things like what's your favorite drink
or
what kind of skin do you have or do you
smoke and i'm like
well i can tell you that i don't smoke
and that i like fruit juice but
i don't know what kind of skin that i
have and then you look at their options
like oh i guess mine is kind of dry and
sensitive because i get
weird bumps in places um eric move on
eric move on eric move on okay
uh it was actually really really easy to
take this quiz it took less time than i
normally spend double checking to
remember if i put on deodorant today
it takes forever for me to determine
that move on eric eric the products they
sent me were great they sent me this
whole box of stuff but there's this body
wash
that like this is the only body wash i
want to use ever again it
it smells so good and it's like they
really did make something that's
tailored for me this is exactly what i
want to smell like
i feel so good at my skin before i was
walking in the shower feeling so dry
and chalky you know throughout the day
and sticky and itchy and now it's like
no this is good this is
what i should have felt all this time
this is the way eric's been using face
soap for body wash
and every woman in the world is like
what are you doing it's a great way to
build personalized gifts for the guys in
your life and to show that you care
enough to get them a gift tailored to
their needs you're welcome uncle doug
hawthorne is a fun and convenient way to
get super high quality products
tailored specifically for men hawthorne
even takes the risk out of it by giving
you free shipping
on your order in returns if you don't
like their products they'll even
retailer them based on your feedback
get special offers for the holidays
going on right now by visiting
hawthorne.co
that is h-a-w-t-h-o-r-n-e
dot c-o to check out their special
holiday offers hawthorne.co
we also want to thank our friends at
hellofresh america's number one meal kit
hellofresh lets you skip those trips to
the grocery store and makes home cooking
easy fun and affordable
they offer convenient no contact
delivery to your doorstep for
easy home cooking with the family
hellofresh's high quality pre-portioned
ingredients help you make meals that are
both nutritious
and so tasty they're worth a trip to the
dark dimension and back
you can easily change your delivery days
or your meal plan preferences so you can
skip a week whenever you need
right on the hellofresh app not long ago
i got this hella fresh recipe for crispy
buffalo spiced chicken with mashed
potatoes and roasted carrots
they have this blue cheese sauce that
went over it it was really freaking good
it was like a beck told style
thanksgiving
i felt like i was eating it with uncle
tommy now you might have heard me
mention green chef recently hello fresh
actually owns green chef and
every plate which allows them to offer a
wider array of meal plans to choose from
i love switching between these hello
chef one week green chef the other when
my tastes change or when i want to eat a
little differently
now my listeners can enjoy both brands
at a discount with me
go to hellofresh.com bigquestion90 and
use the code bigquestion90 to get 90
off including free shipping that's 90
off and free shipping on your order when
you go to hellofresh.com
bigquestion90 and use the code
bigquestion90. if you eat what eric eats
at the same time that eric eats it then
you become eric
yeah i think we do a freaky friday and
then that's the only way i'm going to
escape from here so please please do
this
oh boy okay now because the time for a
bite size question that
marina and i are going to tag team so
civilian on discord asks
if thor was in better shape when he
faced thanos and in game
would tony stark be alive right now boy
we are fat shaming fat thor
eric oh my god i guess that's what we're
doing that's what they ask we're gonna
deliver we gotta ask this question
did michelle obama put this in there i
know she's concerned about our physical
we gotta be fit and ready to fight when
thanos comes i can see
why one would ask only because
compared to how he used to be does that
make a difference right and we can
say that for the most part no
which you know is an answer to like you
know should we be fat shaming no because
it really
you can be fit at any size that's right
so for the most part
thor's poor physical condition doesn't
really hold anyone back when they fight
thanos
if you watch that battle like he's not
really impeding anybody
um if anything he's a smarter fighter in
endgame
than he is in infinity war so if you
look closely the first move he makes
in the three-on-one fight is a blow to
thanos's head so
he goes for the head which is what he
said he was gonna do that's right he
learned the big lesson
and brenda there's also that moment that
uh tony calls thor
lebowski when he's on his way but he's
like kind of innocent
tony's helping rocket build the quantum
tunnel but
you know i i don't think he slowed him
down that much i think you know getting
done with that tunnel faster wouldn't
change anything when you have a time
machine you can go back to any point
they weren't really in a rush to finish
that well also
during the time heist thor's drunkenness
makes him pretty useless in asgard so
i'd argue that's more of a thing than
being overweight
um rocking does all the heavy lifting so
if thor
had joined rhodian nebula he might have
been able to prevent
nebula from falling into 2014 thanos's
hands avoiding the final battle
altogether but if thor wasn't an asgard
he wouldn't have gotten a second mule in
there for cap to use later so take your
break that's true
we needed that we needed that big moment
it's like the best moment of in-game so
we needed to be there
and then yeah that brings us to that
three-on-one fight that you mentioned
marina there
is one moment that we have to call out
thor does use stormbreaker to
bat mjolnir at thanos and then thanos
kind of uses iron man as a human shield
and that is kind of what briefly ko's
tony
[Music]
arguably if thor had been less clumsy
that wouldn't have happened i i think
thor could have done that even if he was
in peak physical condition
that doesn't necessarily mean they'd be
able to kill thanos sooner than
was in pretty good shape for that fight
and thor had pretty bad aim even when he
was ripped
[Music]
his weight had pretty much nothing to do
with closing in your size don't really
go together i've been clumsy my entire
life even when i was a little twiggy boy
boy
i was one of those twiggy boys with the
huge horse adam's apple you know
just like i grew awkwardly and i could
not dance i could not play sports i was
clumsy and lazy
i'm sure not all those things um and
plus look at you now
a shining example of uh handsomeness and
charisma
charisma
tumbles don't worry guys i'm really tiny
and i can't do anything and i'm not
coordinated at all
so um you could argue that if thor
wasn't so big
and drunk that he would have been able
to pick up the gauntlet and
use it to snap everybody because you
know tony told him to sit out because he
wasn't in the state to handle it
but i think he was talking about an
emotional state because right before
that
he makes that speech he starts like
talking about jane
and he really just like has a breakdown
and to me that's reflective of a
mental and emotional state more than a
physical state yeah agreed and that only
would have helped banners arm from
getting fried but banner took on that
burden himself he said i was made for
this
uh i was made from gamma the stones emit
gamma
i should do this i really think marina
the pivotal moment comes up
right before tony's death there is a
little moment uh when
thor is having his final tussle with
thanos and thor briefly stops thanos
from getting the gauntlet he hits him a
few times to stormbreaker
and then he uses stormbreaker to weigh
down thanos's arm
and then he uses mjolnir to cross it
over to really weigh down the arm
because we know
uh thanos cannot lift mjolnir but this
whole time
thanos's left hand is just kind of free
it's just kind of there he's just kind
of like
okay i'm not gonna use it and thanos
uses that left hand to
bat down stormbreaker to knock thor away
from him and i would argue it wasn't
thor it was
cap cap jumps on thanos his shoulders in
that moment which
doesn't it kind of weighs things down
but it doesn't do anything to help he
should have grabbed
thanos left hand that is the hand that
cap actually had grabbed before an
infinity war cap
knew he could hold it back and if he had
held back that hand
that would have given thor just enough
time to plunge stormbreaker into thanos
chest
and kill him what the [ __ ] so it's
really cap it's not thor
actually in the moment such good shape
can we just take a moment to just
think and remember what good shape
cap is in we can just like just the best
shape
just really take a moment to savor that
[Music]
that's gonna shape my dreams um
okay so either way eric while we're
dreaming of that later
based on actually dr strange's view of
the future
okay tony was gonna have to make the
sacrifice play
regardless that's right so it was his
own unique nanotech armor's ability to
discreetly absorb the stones off the
gauntlet that
eventually led to thanos defeat but that
also
required tony to give his own life so
thor's health really
had no effect on tony's destiny because
he started strange saw that
before so while thor may be to blame
in infinity war for not going for the
head i think he made
big strides in end game and doesn't
matter what shape he's in he was still
just as fierce a better fighter one
would say and
as clumsy as he always absolutely and he
came to accept himself accept yourself
love yourself that's right he came
oh yeah you know really it's his
attitude that still needs an adjustment
you know at the end when he's able to
look over and let peter quill be the
captain of that ship that's the
captain we need he's the captain what a
hero
what a hero all right marina we have
time just for one final
box of scraps
box subscribers and uh staying with this
theme of the marvel afterlife
our question is have you ever
felt or experienced a supernatural event
that has led you to believe
that an afterlife could be real
yeah i actually have um i'll make it
very quick
but um a long time ago i used to work
for
a different company totally
and the person who was my boss
they had a kid who had passed away
um and they introduced me
to their kid because they're just like
and i really think this is like
healthy and good they kept their kid
really as part of their life
and as part of their the business that i
worked for
and everybody that came to the business
they would be like hey you know like we
really incorporate this person
into the kind of ethos and the culture
of our workplace and
yeah yeah and a lot of um like
sorry non-white cultures are like this
where like people pass away but they
keep them around spiritually
but so i was like literally introduced
to the kid who had passed away by the
dad
and that night okay i woke up at three
in the morning
because if let's say you're in a crowded
room and someone's staring at you you
can like feel it
i woke up because i had that feeling
and i rolled over in my room and there
was like a big
black how do you want to say it like
even though it's night it's not pitch
black but whatever
ambient light there was was being sucked
into a vortex
yeah and that vortex was there and i was
like
and i'm like really into like horror
ghosts you guys know this about me
so i'm not trying to push it i'm not
trying to push it right right you don't
want to scoff at them i'm not trying to
make
anybody mad i was very i was like you
know what
you do you we are fine this is cool
whatever and as soon and in my brain i
was like
we're cool dude we're cool everything's
cool he
like disappeared and so i ran into work
the next day not putting two and two
together and i was like oh my god this
thing happened it appeared in my room
and my boss was like uh that was my kid
obviously
and i was like oh my god of course it
was because he was just like checking me
out and like seeing who
is the new person like working at the
company wow i've got
chills that's so interesting that he was
just like
so nice it's just how you interpreted
what the other
what the passage to the other side was
and it is scary if
you don't know what it is it's scary
right but it doesn't happen
that's so good yeah what about you i i
don't have a personal story i i have my
mom's story so i'm just gonna tell her
version of it i don't want to take it
this is my mom's street it has to do
with my family and
it gives me chills every time she tells
it so i am the um i am the youngest of
five
and my mom you know god bless her she
raised all of us
and uh my dad's in the pictures
[Music]
but my dad was in the navy he was on
deployment a lot
[Music]
so my mom she did kind of have to like
you know
be the earth mom and take care of all
these kids uh
and the first kid she had was my older
sister
and my mom was young she was in her
early 20s
and it was a it was a rough delivery um
my mom was in rough shape and she almost
did not make him they had to tell my dad
to leave
the room uh my mom was losing a lot of
blood and
uh so my mom was just she just passed
they gave her whatever you know just
kind of knock her out while they did
what they had to do
and she had a vivid uh
vision of her ancestors
um applauding and welcoming her
to the other side oh my god and
the way my mom i'm not doing it just the
way my mom tells us you it's just like
when someone tells a story of something
that really after them with this
conviction and you're like
yes this happened to you this is not
[ __ ] and they were plotting her and
she felt
warm and she felt at peace and was just
like okay i'm ready to go
but she knew in that moment that
she could not go with him
that she had her daughter and her
future kids that she need to stay
on earth to help take care of
so she could not go on and then she woke
up and her
um and there were people there that my
mom didn't recognize but just kind of
knew
she sensed that they were related and
then she described this experience to
her sister
who is who's going through a hard time
right now so um
it means a lot to me that you know my
mom had this connection and she told
this to me out of this connection with
her sister
and her sister told my mom that was
an aunt who died before you were born
she described her to a tea
that is someone you know oh my god or
you would never know someone else
yeah yeah yeah that's how my mom knew
that this was like a real
happen dude so when i hear that story
i'm like yeah okay there's something
there
there's something on the other side also
your mom
is a huge badass
she is a major because they what who
okay so like she almost died and her
ancestors reaction was to applaud her
like they gave her a standing ovation
like
they were like you're doing it you're
you're bringing new life into this
family
like good for you or just like you're a
cool ass
person like you're just the best like if
i die
people are going to be like you're fine
yeah but like your mom like
walked into a standing situation that's
so cool wow
yeah well and whenever i watch movies
that kind of depict it the ones that
have that are parallel to that like
uh like ghosts you know at the end it
goes for swayzes looking out and they're
all these people who like hug him and
greet him it's kind of like
that's what that's so good that's what
it could be
you know yeah yeah oh boy i've got
chills now we got to move on
we gotta
right yeah that's her ancestral plane
well that is it for this episode of big
question i feel like we went to some
very interesting places
and i'm so glad you were here marina
this is so great to chat with you
follow marina at marina mastros uh she's
gonna be on uh more new rockstars videos
we're still kind of you know we're
taking it slow because you got some you
know you're still easing your way back
in
but be sure to follow her support her
everything she does like all of her
tweets
follow her retweet it show me some love
you can also follow me at eavos but you
don't need to like everything i say
most of what i say is just like annoyed
clapbacks for people who say why isn't
the video out yet
just like leave me alone so you don't
need to follow me i don't care but yeah
be sure to follow new rockstars there's
all kinds of great stuff we got coming
out this month and into the new year
you can send us your big questions using
the hashtag question uh you can
subscribe to this podcast feed
wherever you get your podcast leave it's
a nice radiant review if you don't mind
and yeah subscribe to new rockstars here
on youtube hit that notification bell we
will see you next time thank you for
watching
bye-bye stay safe
[Music]
you